oh now you found
what's the first weapon fancy it's time
for another episode of challenge
okay a 360 between every show I know I
[Music]
know I think I changed direction and you
did
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that's good and see it anymore okay
one more one more yeah is the worst
challenge ever
[Music]
[Music]
this is definitely not funny
I think we're gonna have to finish this
challenge here okay so this is a
challenge for you guys can we reach 100k
likes on this video
let's see remember to like so many of
you have wanted me to play with my beard
it's time to try it out I'll try to
attach this racket to my beard that's
now in place but it's there maybe it
will stay for a while that's never gonna
work out but yeah that's that's that's
not gonna work no it's not enough
[Music]
I'm impressed if you get one shot on the
table 100,000 likes for every stroke I
don't forget some table so zero yeah
exactly
oh now you found
unbelievable and it has no Jessica to me
apparently it works yeah I got the
feeling that
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I look
[Music]
[Applause]
oh-ho this is good nice stabilize the
racket
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time for my favorite shots you know what
it is I think this must be so hard
[Music]
okay love this thing so I still have the
world record in the company the game but
can i play this game while I'm playing
table tennis of course
I'll choose am L oh and by the way you
probably haven't seen this but this is
the rooftop this is the best map in the
whole game I don't think God
I've seen it how does it look like nice
this could be a challenge play while
someone else is holding in front okay go
[Music]
it's going well
oh well sixteen and guys go beat my high
score I want to see someone beat my high
score they will challenge to see you
guys yeah that's my challenge to you
guys go beat my high school so I think
you get what we are going to do with
this let's try it out
[Music]
the golden bottom would be big for
anybody okay sighs it's a bit high
otherwise it's okay that's good okay so
off don't play with a button I'll play
the case yeah thanks
I think I'll start it's not keeping my
racket in here it's a bit inconvenient
but I like it it's time for the golden
around neck touch yes
[Music]
golden plate versus silver player I
think that we need plate I think this
one's better about the Reno choice
bigger plate for a bigger man
okay zero zero can I say that was a bad
start
[Music]
haha no chance I'm gonna beat you yes
okay I'll try this side
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody wants to miss we'll be here
tomorrow playing this one point yeah
maybe this is the new verse long it's
Riley maybe the black side is better
I'll finish it with the black side maybe
we don't need to show the whole match we
just say this one point is this long as
a match
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no every time you just give me an easy
ball and I think I can smash it that's
my thank you besides therefore I'm
coming back like stupid
yes damage control it seems to have
survived yeah
first a little fingerprints some more
marks it's functionally improve its
continuity fruit don't forget to
subscribe and what's our previous
leaders there until next time